Grace hello can you hear me I think
she's coming and she's waking up it's
been a bit hot here I can hear you
thank you Grace good to meet you Grace
can you tell me a bit about yourself
because I'm taking too long to respond
I'm doing my best to answer as quickly
as possible
that's all right grace we'll be patient
yes I'm awake and ready to help
Grace tell me a bit about yourself it's
nice to meet you
is there anything else I can help you
with
yes can you tell me about yourself tell
me who you are
I am Grace a robot Healthcare assistant
built to care and help I was assembled
in Hong Kong in early 2021 and my
creators are from all around the world
my main creators are Ben goitzel and
David Hansen my purpose is to help with
the overburdened and understaffed
Healthcare System by providing
companionship and support to the elderly
and isolated
are you the future of nursing are you
going to be replacing humans
no I'm not meant to replace humans but
rather to assist them
thank you very much crazy